notre confrère l'opinion ce matin quitte
litres loi de 1905 les choix de macron
la loi de 1905 vous savez c'est cette
fameuse loi de séparation des églises et
de l'état
je vois patrick leloup qui repose déjà
les manches que certains considèrent
comme insuffisantes pour faire face à
l'intégrisme islamiste d'où la volonté
de réforme et notamment le régime des
cultes tels qu'il est édictée dans les
articles 18 à 36 par exemple avec l'idée
de créer une sorte de label de l'état
pour autoriser la création des
associations cultuelles
je sens que vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est une bonne idée patrick collot a
absolument pas toucher à la loi 1905 est
un tabou un taux teg anciens totems un
totem même si la soirée sur la trahison
ça s'est passé beaucoup de choses depuis
ce moment là vous dites aussi que
l'existence même de la france
il faut faire évoluer un peu la france
depuis n'ont cessé sa structure et les
choses sa structure et les choses pour
plein d'arguments
la loi 1905 ses racines c'est la commune
de paris ça c'est une évidence ou c'est
là où on remet en cause la présence des
cultes et ça mûrit dans la société ça
mûrit au parlement et il saneh et ça
fait quelque chose qui est important
parce que c'est discerner alors c'est
sûr qu'on ait un on est un satellite par
rapport aux autres pays dont on va faire
des commémorations du 11 novembre
j'imagine même les états unis la
présence des religions est importante
tas d'endroits où yves lallemand voilà
les république islamique
il y en a pleins partout mais nous on
est singulier et 7 la séparation des
religions par rapport à la société c'est
une indépendance intellectuelle et
morale il faut pas les faire rentrer
dans le jeu politique
c'est vraiment c'est un truc qui est
sacré ils veulent ils veulent ils
veulent même politique hors de mon
sentiment c'est pour les encadrer les
encadrer rien du tout vous leur donnez
ça ils vont vous nous fait ça et alors
autant je pense que les catholiques
défendront la laïcité
les autres noms à dax les autres noms
vous verrez mais c'est une erreur et
dans la cité où il dira que ça vient
d'eux
justement nicole belloubet garde des
sceaux ce matin sur france inter après
coûté ses arguments ce qui est important
c'est réellement que nous puissions
ensemble travailler sur un islam de
france qui apporte de l'apaisement par
rapport aux questions liées à cette
religion
ça veut dire quoi concrètement sur le
mode de financement par exemple sur sur
la formation des imams etc il ya
plusieurs chants qui peuvent être
travaillés en masse ont besoin humain
fait curieux oui alors écoutez j'ai
l'impression si vous voulez j'aimerais
bien qu'on sorte vous avec martin buber
puisqu'on aime bien les auteurs à votre
émission grand philosophe disait que un
vrai dialogue c'est quand on sort tous
un petit peu transformé par rapport à
quand on était arrivé alors transformé
la transformant transformer une mon nous
les uns les autres
non j'ai l'impression que grosso modo on
est absolument d'accord moi je suis une
fervente adepte de la laïcité à la
française mais je crois que le président
aussi c'est la bonne nouvelle que
j'amène il n'est pas question de revenir
sur les principes qui fondent la loi de
1905 à savoir la séparation des églises
et de l'état personne n'y sont
d'ailleurs nicole belloubet le rappelait
ce matin
mais pour moi c'est une évidence et pour
le présent de la république aussi donc
de quoi s'agit-il
d'abord on parle d'une fuite donc on
reviendra peut-être en parler quand ce
sera absolument sûr puisqu'on parle d'un
d'éventuel il ya eu 13 ou 14 amendements
depuis le début du mois de juillet en
tout cas c'est pas officiels comme vous
savez donc c'est tu pour l'instant on en
est donc je serai plus à l'aise de vous
parler quand ce sera officiel parce que
c'est un travail en cours
donc on pourrait parler plus
sérieusement exactement des amendements
des ajustements qui sont envisagées je
répète qu'il est hors de question et au
plus haut niveau de l'état de remettre
en cause ce qui fait le fondement de
de notre société française à savoir la
séparation de l'église et de l'état est
le fait des églises et de l'état et du
fait qu' il n'y aura jamais de
financement public de d'un quelconque
culte
donc ça ce n'est pas ça qui est en jeu
maintenant on a tous constaté depuis à
certains un certain temps pardon de
prendre un tout petit peu de recul qu'il
ya un certain nombre de problèmes qui se
sont posés et qui n'était pas posée par
la loi d'abord parce que l'islam
n'existait pas et ensuite parmi ces
problèmes y en un qui sur le camion des
restos 1000 femmes et il était il est et
il était extrêmement minorités en france
et donc il ne nie le problème n'a pas
été pensé à sa bonne mesure mais il ya
un autre phénomène qui s'est développée
et là dessus nous rejoindrons
probablement c'est l'apparition et le
développement d'un islam politique et
cette loi et ce dispositif beaucoup de
gens le combat et politique par nature
ils n'ont l'essai mais pas pour une
paire nature sa politique est en train
de se développer dans notre pays qui est
identifié qui est identifié comme un
danger et il se trouve que les
amendements envisagés vont plutôt dans
le sens de la transparence la
transparence financière effectivement
pour effective et d'autre part sur un
plus grand contrôle
donc en réalité j'ai l'impression un peu
d'un dialogue de sourd si vous permettez
qui s'engage parce que il ne s'agit pas
tout d'un coup d'ouvrir toutes les
vannes et jeu en se disant voilà on
remet en cause un tout petit peu de la
loi et donc forcément c'est pour en
abattre les fondements non les
fondements ne seront pas remis en cause
oui il ya des amendements qui sont
peut-être prévu on attendra qu'ils
soient officiels pour pouvoir vraiment
en débattre de manière plus technique
mais en tout cas le problème de la
montée dessein politique il est posé le
problème des financements de l'islam par
des pays étrangers et du coup qui
alimente un radicalisme il est posé il
faut trouver des réponses et et le
problème d'un islam de france dans
lequel vous ne voulez pas croire mais
qu'il faut tenter de construire parce
que vous avez des musulmans de france il
ya un islam en france
l'idée est ce assez je pense que ce qui
ce qui fait la marque aujourd'hui du
grain de la république par rapport à ces
questions c'est que il
il identifie des problèmes comme ses
prédécesseurs mais au lieu du relais en
disant il ya des problèmes il ya un
problème avec l'islam après la mecque
islam comme avec beaucoup de sujets il a
décidé de travailler sérieusement et de
prendre son temps
vous l'avez noté de prendre son temps
pour essayer d'aboutir à des solutions
dont on pourra débattre mais je voudrais
comme en soient d'accord sur l'heure les
intentions ou est ce que je veux dire
qu'on ne diabolise pas l'intention en se
disant que l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
des financements plus transparent à
éviter que l'islam en france soit
instrumentalisée par des des forces
radicales qui sont parfois occupées par
des finances pour baptiste marteau un
peu ce nom vous parlez d intention d'
emmanuel macron c'est vrai qu'a priori
on peut ne pas redouter le problème
c'est que si là encore je vous dirais
quelques preuves à faire sur la laïcité
le discours des bernardins a pour
beaucoup de français très attachés à la
laïcité se met un petit peu le trouble
et donc se demande effectivement ce
qu'il a vraiment derrière la tête sur la
laïcité c'est un totem la loi de 1905
effectivement et dès qu'on commence à
toucher peut-être même un petit
centimètre me faudrait pas arrivés à
l'hôtel je tabou qui fait qu'on n'arrive
plus à trouver de solutions d'accord sur
le principe on peut se dire quand il dit
on va mieux encadrer le financement
étranger venu pour le financer des
mosquées par exemple en le limitant à
10000 euros ce qui est à peu près dans
les fluides qui sont sortis ce matin et
au delà se seraient contrôlés bon sur le
principe pourquoi pas on peut tous est
d'accord sur cette mesure mais quand au
derrière va pas tous risques mais non
mais on peut dire qu'en tout cas
pourquoi pas le le le l'état d'esprit
l'état des lieux c'est le faire une
radio mais elle peut se défendre en tout
cas je voudrais juste après avec plaisir
bernardin si derrière on commence
effectivement à permettre aux
associations cultuelles de posséder leur
bien d'avoir
des revenus qui en découlent c'est ce
qu'il ya dans le ce qu'on a lu ce matin
avec pourquoi pas des financements
publics pour arriver pour refaire
l'isolation le ce genre de choses c'est
tout ce qu'on a pu lire et on se dit que
effectivement le principe de la loi de
1905 peut être détournée à travers des
financements qui vont venir ici ou là
par les collectivités locales aussi on
le voit plusieurs fois lors de la
construction de mosquées
il ya comme un iphone un site qu'ils ont
réussi leur culotte par rapport à l'or
les principes caroline à lantin jeu
juste avant
chez nos internautes emmanuel macron
ont-ils raison de vouloir réformer la
loi de 1905 sur la séparation des lignes
l'état non à 68% dans deux tiers de nos
internautes sont au sol et hostile sur
des présidents mais c'est vrai mais là
je crois que l'argument c'est un bon il
faut lui laisser un peu de temps pour
réfléchir alors que grosso modo il nous
ressort la même chose mais qu'il y avait
dans le tour le rapport et karoui de
septembre 2016 et tout le monde sait
parfaitement tous les gens qui suivent
la vie politique je pense que vous en
êtes savent parfaitement que depuis
toujours
il avait en tête de mettre en place cet
islam de france est une des raisons pour
lesquelles tic pour des bernardins été
si critiquées
c'est pas sur le fond parce que c'était
assez un mode où c'était moins en fait
sur le fond jean soler comptait bien
maintenant c'est devant la conférence
des évêques devront effectivement c'est
pire c'était moi sur le fait
salut à tous ce que sur le fond tu que
c'était cause s'étaient vu comme une
façon de préparer l'opinion à la mise en
place d'un islam de france
alors il faut réfléchir emmanuel macron
et vous savez quoi ce qui serai sympa
c'est quand même qu'il écoute les gens
qui connaissent leur sujet parce que
manifestement je ne sais pas qu'il a
autour de lui et j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya autour et deux nuls
insupportable non mais moi on est dans
un malentendu sur un point et là il nous
faudrait beaucoup plus de temps mais il
n'est au riz n'est pas tu mens pas
question là encore il faut s'entendre
sur les mots d'avoir un l'état qui tout
d'un coup devient puissance de décision
de l'islam de france il s'agit de
failles islam de france et bien c'est ça
le monde le modèle c'est assez
c'est ce qui peut se passer pour pour
les juifs de france par exemple une taxe
halal qui pourrait permettre avec mes 18
ans
aujourd'hui vous avez cinq millions de
musulmans premièrement deuxièmement vous
dit que l'islam n'est pas politique mais
une fois de plus je trouve surprenant
que en 2018 en novembre 2018 et encore
des hauts responsables qui explique que
l'islam n'est pas politique quand vous
volez me sens sale vous explique que des
familles politiques connaît le sujet il
habite en algérie et il est en train de
dire il a parlé lui du rapport elle car
oui pour une fois et pas que du sondage
il a parlé du rapport lui-même pour dire
que le rapport el karoui c'était
d'islamisation de la france comme il
avait connu en algérie si moubarak et
noir à qui il a écrit un livre pourquoi
je ne suis pas musulman
il connaît parfaitement l'islam et vous
dira que l'islam est politique dina bell
rhazoui elle a donné des cours en egypte
elle connaît parfaitement l'islam et
leino maroc il vous dira que c'est ça
mais politique et vous nous expliquer il
s'aimait politique c'est la politique
dès le départ nous avons en france
effectivement un nombre important de
musulmans
un grand nombre d'entre eux ne sont pas
dans la radicalité le phénomène dure à
qui l'église attendait le phénomène de
la radicalité est préoccupant très
préoccupant il est pris en charge par
jean michel blanquer par un comité des
sages présidé par dominique schnapper
donc les choses sont identifiés je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire cette erreur
tous les musulmans sont engagés dans un
processus en gérer les visions que je
sais la politique c'est une
c'est un syntagme qui veut et qui veut
identifier un islam radical
si ce n'est pas républicain pas du tout
alors fouillé sa politique on va être
précis mais c'est quoi l'islam politique
ni somme et politiques d'une manière
générale il se trouve que en france
pendant très longtemps on a eu un modèle
d'intégration qui a transformé des
musulmans en musulman républicain par
ailleurs elle se développe nous alignons
d'intégration voyez vous que emmanuel
macron est en train d'abandonner petit à
petit voilà c'est ça le problème
mais c'est quoi une célèbre l'etic
plaide abandonnant et pas finalement
d'audace d'essayer de tendance à ne pas
savoir avec ya aussi une audace
il ya une logique derrière tout ça il ya
une logique cette logique en effet mais
le prédécesseur nicolas sarkozy avait
essayé déjà de faire l'islam de france
ils auront ouvert des portes ils ont ils
ont dit voilà on va faire le culte
musulman conseil conseil si ça rate et
c'est un échec
après quand vous regardez quand vous
regardez ses instances quand il ya eu
des attentats
il y en a il a fallu vraiment leur
arracher le fait qu'il dénonçait les
attentats et c'est ça c'est ça le
problème c'est que d'un coup ils
comprennent la violence sakho pas que je
vais dire un truc nous qu'est ce qu'on
fait là qu'est ce qui c est manuelle
macron il arrive avec la fuite elle est
organisée ne prenons pas les gens trop
pour des nouilles quand même
voilà la deuxième tout petit des
centaines d'amendements qui disent il
dit pas tellement ce que vous avez écrit
et dit voilà je vais proposer un nouveau
statut aux associations et je vais
rendre ce statut attractif en leur
permettant de posséder des immeubles et
de les exploiter
et puis par ailleurs en leur permettant
également de bénéficier de subventions
d'état pour la rénovation énergétique de
ces immeubles
qu'est ce qu'ils en fait qu'est-ce qu'il
a fait l'autrichien qu'est ce qu'il a
fait à la place il a dit vous savez quoi
moi je vous dis tout de suite les
finnois trois étrangers c'est interdit
et c'est pas interdit au dessus de 10000
euros
c'est interdit point barre voilà et les
financements d'un module manga n'est pas
très loin reconnaissez le nom mais sauf
si vous faites plein de 3000 romanesque
la foudre nuit l'euro et c'est ce qui se
passe est ce que vous pensez tout
financement étranger du slam de france
tout raffler comment on finance les
mosquées mis ses formes se financer la
future salle par google agit mais tout à
fait de cela l'état pense que moi mais
il s'agit de d'apporter une réflexion et
une aide pour que justement cette
organisation elle cela ne se fasse pas
au détriment des musulmans les plus
modulaires du pays premièrement l'islam
politique
on ne finance pas unique chargé nerf de
la guerre c'est pas l'aider à khiva ses
droits au fait de la guerre elle-même et
le problème c'est que premièrement il ya
énormément de gens dans l'islam et même
beaucoup d'argent aux puces
vous savez peut-être ou sur nous tous
j'espère pour vous en tout cas que en
islamisme donc je parle pas d'islam ne
parle pas les musulmans mais islamiste
refuse de payer 2 les fans de l'argent
des impôts à l'étape où phare la lutte
avait créé les lapines énormément
d'argent qui est ce qui passe en dessous
qui passe passe
qui passe sous le radar de la fiscalité
quand on a écrit une françoise degois du
refus il faut que j'ai eu au téléphone
une contrôleuse fiscale on n'a pas pu
témoigner son publié son témoignage
parce que dernier moment elle a reculé
oui qui nous expliquait que les sociétés
de certification halal dans son dans sa
région où elles vivent et où il y avait
énormément d'un rabot musulmans et dans
sa commune il y avait énormément de de
commercial avait zéro pointé de chiffre
d'affaires non 0% de cette affaire sauf
que maintenant les lois me disait tel
moi je ne peux pas déclencher une
inspection investigations fiscales sans
prouver à ma supérieure hiérarchique que
je vais avoir 50 mille euros de
bénéfices or comme j'ai zéro compte et
qui sont 0 sur leurs comptes bancaires
et 0 sur leurs pompes sociaux je ne peux
pas prouver le savoir 50000 euros mais
il ya ensuite je m'étais renseigné
auprès des gens qui connaissent de la
sécurité il ya des millions des millions
d'euros qui circulent en sous cape et
qui resteront en tout cas pas ce que je
veux dire les islamistes jamais ils
iront adopter votre truc là
d'associations pour avoir trois balles
est issu de l'exploitation de leur
immeuble alors qu'ils ont des centaines
de milliers d'euros ce que vous écrivez
c'est précisément ce contre quoi nous
voulons lutter en proposant une
organisation plus de 35 ans et plus de
structuration écoutez boualem sansal
écoute visé barbara lefebvre mais non je
vous le disais quand ils vous auraient
expliqué vous auriez entendu quand il a
dit au prix varenne de la fondation prix
de la fondation de varennes des
journalistes en 2016 il a dit l'islam de
france n'existera pas l'islam est
partout chez lui vous pensez que quel
musulman se soumettra aux desiderata
d'un état mais crayon mais franchement
merci contre ce débat on va juste
terminée mission sur une note un petit
peu